i never realized that they had the dj's
have one deck
not two which is a really crucial thing
because like a night we go to a
club and there's two decks and they mix
them it's seamless but these guys don't
do that
they stop the record put sound effects
on and then put another one on really
quickly and
it's really bizarre but it actually
creates a really unique sound
and in terms of the edit it gave us a
lot more stuff to play with
sound effects this kind of stuff you
know and so
so it was a slowly we've gotten more and
more immersed in that world
you've got to emotionally connect with
this and stitch this
epic yeah definite scenarios together in
a way that's authentic and true
that's a big feat for something that you
might not necessarily know so what was
your
what was your what was the thing that
made it click for you and then yeah
this is how i'm gonna do it well i mean
like like helen and i mean i
i lived through lived through a lot
apart from mangrove
which was before i was was only just
born then
so i i remember i remember the brixton
riots i remember the birmingham riots
i remember you know like parties like
lovers rock sound systems going to
nottingham
carnival things like that but from a
different point of view
which is the really crucial thing about
it and
so i this was like another country for
me
this is what i i saw was like oh is this
the same place that i've lived in for
the last 40
40 years 40 50 years or something and of
course that was that
that was the sort of path that i went
and so steve and i had lots of
conversations about
music what sort of music i was into and
i was sort of
into punk rock and things like that
which actually had quite a lot of
um not similarities in in the music but
in the attitude
reggae and reggae and punk had a big had
a kind of like a fusion and
it was happening in notting hill and
that and so
you know steve and i talked about that
type of thing
and you know what we're into but also
what filmmakers from that time
and so that was a sort of journey you
know we apart from
you know exploring the kind of like the
music which
i mean going back to the music that was
a massive part of the films
i mean particularly alex wheat or lovers
rock and even mangrove is like sort of
it gave it an identity and
we did a lot of work on it like that is
and it sort of helped to give it
life you you know and so that was a that
was a big key for me and like and
particularly in
love as rocks rediscovering that music
which i
i knew some of it but like i didn't know
a lot of
the rest of it and so discovering all
that again was just like for me was just
something incredible and and of course
at a party like that i
i never realized that they had the dj's
have one deck
not two which is a really crucial thing
because like a night we go to a
club and there's two decks and they mix
them it's seamless but these guys don't
do that
they stop the record put sound effects
on and then put another one on really
quickly and
it's really bizarre but it actually
creates a really unique sound
and in terms of the edit it gave us a
lot more stuff to play with
sound effects this kind of stuff you
know and so
so it was a slowly we've gotten more and
more immersed in that world
um and what was i saying yeah and about
filmmakers and about the
essentially all the stories were
different but they had a kind of very
sort of truth about them in terms of
their
the way they were shot you know there
was not no frills really
essentially as and in a way that we we
did a
i loved like alan clark who was like
sort of did a lot of movies in the eight
seventies eighties and that steve was
one of our references
the movies the tv films and things that
he made which
you know like made in britain and things
like that you know which were really
kind of straightforward
sort of storytelling but like full of
life and
and that was kind of how the whole thing
began that's what i had in my head
and um yeah and then again
i lived through the period so i had a
lot of reference personal references but
just from a different point of view
thank you jacqueline what
you said that is you know you've got to
try and find
an angle that's not been seen before so
you know we've seen
the 70s visualized in so many different
ways it's not so much that you don't
want to use something that's been seen
before
in a way but what happens a lot with 70s
clothes is that we reuse them
so so we keep making them fashionable
again so there's like a 90s way of
wearing the 70s and there's a
2000s way and it means that it doesn't
cut like it
kind of takes away from something that
you feel about the period
so in order to get to the period you
want to find things that haven't been
like overused
and also you just want to make sure that
people wear the clothes if you do find
like the original piece that's exactly
the right thing you then have to be sure
that you wear it in the way it was worn
then
not the way we would wear it now if we
reappropriate it
so it was about that it was trying to
get back to something that would feel
it wouldn't feel kind of tired or too
familiar
it would feel like something that was
definitely part of the period
so it was that really but anyway sorry i
interrupted you but that's fine
no that's good because it's it was i had
kind of misinterpreted what you're
saying and that's a real clear um
explanation
and but also then how do you not
let the characters become caricatures
of this time and of this moment and
pulling the authenticity that was it was
it a struggle or was this any was this
a different project of anything you've
done before was there anything you
learned new
or had to kind of like i'm not
experienced i'm starting fresh in this
point
so that was actually my main thing that
that was the main thing that i
when this when i spoke to steve and when
i realized that i was gonna
do the job and i really wanted
to do it like in the to the very best
that i could and what i what i want to
do is i really wanted to get something
i wanted to get the sort of an authentic
diversity into it in the sense that i
didn't want it to i didn't want to pick
up the same old things that people pick
up again and again
that they say signify that period or or
that kind of person and i wanted to look
more closely and in greater detail at
the reference
and i wanted to really try and get back
to something that was more authentic
and so in that sense that's why that
ties into what i just said about not
wanting to
kind of use things that are a bit tired
because they get used over and over
again
you can kind of find different things
about that you can give to different
characters
and and then it's all it's also about a
balance just like everything else is so
that you want
you know the way you dress your
principal characters is slightly
different
to ways you may dress the crowd just
because you want them to be more
noticeable but
one of the amazing things i think about
lovers rock which
speaks to every all of us in all the
departments and
and obviously largely to steve and
chabier
is the fact that lover's rock just
didn't really have
principal actors it did have principal
actors obviously it had the protagonist
but it
but the the context and the crowd and
everybody in the scenes was
equally as important and so there wasn't
that sort of
difference between the crowd and the
principles it really was a party and
i've never really experienced that
before because it was largely a joyful
experience watching the party it was
it was really important to
um to try to stylize it a bit without
compromising what we wanted to do in
terms of authenticity but just to tweak
it
so that it became
something beautiful and steve has
mentioned before that slightly fairytale
and magical but something
almost like it was how you wanted to
remember parties were
you know there was something really kind
of special about it so in that sense
it's slightly heightened
you